for the past two decades the nagoro
gabak conflict has dominated the
geopolitics of azerbajan and Armenia
last month in April 2016 a 4-day long
Skirmish erupted which cost the lives of
at least 200 soldiers in a previous
Caspian report we explained the
geopolitical and Military status quo we
also recounted how the conflict is a
potential hotspot that could involve
Regional players such as Russia and
turkey given the geopolitical
significance of the nagoro gabak
conflict and the lack of proper
materials on the subject in this report
we will go over the origins of the
conflict my name is shiran and this is
Caspian report for more information on
the Channel please visit the patreon
page the history of azer Banis and
Armenians in gabak is a complicated one
a number of studies show that the
genetic traces of both ethnicities are
actually closely intertwined the
languages religions and Customs may have
changed over time but in essence both
communities along with many other ethnic
groups share the heritage of the
Caucasus region this narrative is not
accepted by the national paradigms in
fact each side tries to belittle the
history of the other but both Nations
had lost their independent kingdoms
centuries ago to neighboring Empires yet
what Armenians and azer Banis consider
their lands lies right at the crossroads
of Empires for centuries the ottoman
Sultans the Iranian sha and the Russian
tars contested the lands in the South
Caucasus and fought many wars over it
during the territorial exchanges the
borders were redrawn the names of towns
were renamed and every Empire tried to
change the demographics in their favor
by deporting and settling ethnic groups
even though the South caucuses lived
under the shadows of Empires the locals
usually got along fine azer Banis who
share linguistic ties with turkey and a
Shia Muslim Creed with Iran coexisted
with Oriental Orthodox Armenians who
share the regional Customs then in the
19th century the Russian Empire broke
the Power Balance and annexed Iran's
portion of the Caucasus this included
the region of gabak which means black
garden in the AER bani language
following this the Russians conducted
demographic surveys in the newly
conquered territories to assess the
Strategic needs the earliest objective
demographic survey of the gabak region
dates to
1823 according to the statistics 91% of
the population was Muslim and the
remainder was Christian this obviously
refers to Muslim aeran and Christian
Armenians the Russians proceeded to
abolish the former Iranian provinces and
created new ones what is now azerbajan
and Armenia were part of three provinces
the Baku Governor the Elizabeth Paul
governor and the yavan governor the last
demographic survey in these provinces
was conducted in 1897 and the ethn
layout was as the following first
58.7% of the bakco governorate consisted
of ethnic AER Banis while Armenians
formed
6.3% second the Elizabeth Paul region
had an aarani population of at least
60.8% and an Armenian population of
33.3% finally the third Province the
yean governorate consisted of
37.8% % azer Banis and
53.2% Armenians Within These provinces
were secondary administrative divisions
called ues This is where things get even
more complicated for example even though
ethnic aeran is formed the overall
majority in the Elizabeth pole
governorate the ethnic layout of the
shinski region consisted of
53.3% Armenians and 45.3%
AER Banis at the same time the
population of the yavan uest which is
now the capital of Armenia consisted of
51.4% azer Banis and
38.5% Armenians another example is the
nak shavan region which was part of the
yavan governorate but had a
63.7% aarani majority and a
34.4% Armenian minority if even though
the demographic layout changed over time
these administrative Arrangements
remained in place until the Russian
Civil War in
1917 these numbers are the earliest
objective demographic observations of
the region and they show just how
widespread and intermingled both
communities lived when the Russian
Empire collapsed in 1917 azer Banis and
Armenians along with neighboring
Georgians seized the opportunity and
declared a UNIF by transcaucasian state
however nationalist sentiment was
running High and the concept didn't last
as all three nations dismantled in
independent States since the territorial
boundaries were still based on the
Russian governorates and uas territorial
disputes followed Georgia and Armenia
waged a brief war in which Armenia
gained the L province which until 1917
was part of the tii governor it but a
much larger larger War erupted between
azerbajan and Armenia over a number of
territories including sumaru yavan Zang
gazur Nan and gabak at the time most of
the International Community had
recognized sumaru and yavan as part of
Armenia and nahan zeng gazur and gabak
as part of azerbajan regardless of this
revolts appeared all over the region
what's more is that at the time Baku was
the largest oil producing region in the
world the Strategic significance of oil
attracted new empires to the region the
Ottoman and British Empires attempted to
gain influence and control the fates of
the newly established Armenian and azer
bani republics so the first Armenian
aarani War played out in the context of
World War I it was a bland of complex
alliances diplomatic negotiations
military raids and Rogue generals as
well as Imperial
Ambitions both sides made gains and
losses and at the backdrop of the war
azer bani civilians were massacred and
Armenian Villages were pillaged
eventually in 1920 the aarani Army
managed to gain control over most of its
territorial claims concerning Nan Zang
gazur and gabah however in early April
1920 news reached the authorities in
Baku that the Red Army was intent on
Conquering the oil Rich aeran Baku faced
a difficult decision and transferred all
its military forces to fight off the
Soviet invasion of azerbajan following
this the abandoned azer bani positions
in zazul and gabak were overrun by
Armenian forces but the situation was
not to last when the Red Army finished
conquering aeran they marched straight
into Armenia and then Georgia for the
Caucasus the short experience with
Independence came to an end following
the Soviet Conquest the Bolsheviks
established the cuff buau in
1921 the committee led by Stalin was to
supervise the subordination of the
Caucasus into the Soviet Union the
authorities in yavan intended to use
diplomacy to gain control over nakan
zenun and gabak which had previously
been recognized as part of azerbajan
Armenia proceeded to request the
authorities in Moscow for territorial
adjustments and so the cuf buau
committee assessed the territorial
claims by Armenia against azerbajan and
then settled them the committee ruled
that for historic demographic economic
and political reasons the gabak region
was to remain part of azerbajan
nowadays many media Outlets inaccurately
simplify the events by stating that
Stalin gave gabak to aeran however the
original document of the C Bureau makes
no mention of giving transfer or
annexation it only mentions that gabak
remained part of azerbajan in essence
when the Soviet Army invaded the region
they recognized the authority of aeran
over gabak and later settled to conflict
in favor of Baku however in 1923 as a
compromise Stalin made additional
territorial changes as a means to
maintain a Power Balance in the region
the Soviet authorities created the
nagoro kabak autonomous region within
azerbajan the borders of this new
autonomy were drawn specifically to
establish an Armenian majority
population furthermore the region of
Zang gazur despite having an aarani
majority was transferred to Armenia and
this transferred nahan into an exclave
which too was granted an autonomy within
azerbajan a complicated issue just got
even more confusing as the azer bani and
Armenian communities were integrated
into the Soviet Union the Communist
leaders of both republics continued
their attempts to change the demographic
layouts over the next few decades ethnic
azerb Janis from Zang gazur and yavan
were deported as were Armenians deported
from nakan a region that was once home
to Multicultural communities gradually
transformed into distinct Modern Nation
States it took a long time before both
communities learned to trust and
cooperate with each other but during the
Soviet era azer Banis and Armenians
lived and worked side by side the
reconciliation process was made easier
due to the fact that both groups have
much in common in terms of culture in
fact there was a genuine friendship
between the two communities yet in the
final years of the Soviet Union the old
feelings of mutual distrust and
hostility reemerged despite Decades of
peace and trust it only took a small
number of Unfortunate Events to
reintroduce a full-blown conflict it is
for this reason that historians argued
that the Russians had never settled the
conflict rather they had installed the
conditions for a divide and Rule
strategy it was the Fair of an allout
war that kept the Soviet Union together
and without Russian oversight Armenians
and Aeris were destined to wage Another
War and that is exactly what happened in
the aftermath of the collapse of the
Soviet Union eventually the relations
reached a boiling point when the
authorities in nagoro gabak voted for a
unification with Armenia tensions
between the two groups escalated azer
Janis were deported from Armenia and
ethnic Armenians became targets for
nationalists in azerbajan and the Soviet
state media only made matters worse
sporadic violence erupted all over the
region people were getting killed on
both sides the situation only worsened
with the formal collapse of the the
Soviet Union the status of Affairs
lasted from 1988 to
1992 yet despite all the violence even
in the early days of the conflict both
sides aimed to prevent a war in fact a
consensus between yavan and Baku was
reached in September
1991 Armenia renounced all its claims to
azer bani territory and this became
known as the jelis naot Declaration
however the peace treaty was disrupted
when a peacekeeping delegation aboard a
transport helicopter consisting of
Russian and kazak observers as well as a
dozen high-ranking azabani State
officials was shot down all the
passengers were killed in the crash and
an investigation committee revealed that
the helicopter was shot down from the
ground by large caliber weapons there
are many conspiracy theories on the
shootdown of the helicopter ranging from
Russian KGB interference to Rogue
generals but what we do know for certain
is that as a result of the sabotage the
peace treaty between aeran and Armenia
was never ratified as the conflict
escalated both sides started targeting
civilians and committed various acts of
war crimes and atrocities the most
infamous of these events was the Kali
massacre in which the Russian 366th
motor rival regiment was directly
involved the news of the Massacre had
such a profound impact that it forced
the resignation of the azer bani
president mutalibov and as the level of
hostility increased former friends and
neighbors became enemies it seemed that
war was Unstoppable yet cool heads still
prevailed in Baku and yavan as both
sides once again attempted to reconcile
this time the presidents of Armenia and
aeran met in Iran in what is now known
as the tan agreement both sides es
committed themselves to peace and agreed
to withdraw their armies from the
conflict Zone however the peace efforts
failed the very next day when Armenian
troops in breach of the tan agreement
attacked and captured the azer bani town
of shusa following this the negotiation
ceased and a fullscale war ensued it's
important to note that President ter
petosan of Armenia had not actually
planned to double cross his azer bani
counterpart rather The Armenian
president was not in control of his
military forces someone else was calling
the shots and two times already a
peaceful outcome had been sabotaged but
even at the time it was evident that
some third party was determined to force
azerbajan and Armenia into a war and
push out any Iranian influence by
embarrassing Ton's political efforts
ultimately the country that gained the
most from these subversions was Russia
there is no evidence to prove this but
many analysts consider either the KGB or
the gru responsible for instigating a
war between Armenia and azerbajan as it
made the South Caucasus more manageable
for Moscow either way the collapse of
the peace talks paided the way for a
fullscale war between Armenian and
aarani troops however ever since the
fall of shusa which is the most
strategic point in gabak and the Cradle
of aarani culture the political
divisions in Baku deepened an armed
Revolt Ed the acting president only to
be replaced by the former communist
president who to was replaced in an
election and then the elected president
was deposed in a coup with the azanis
distracted in a political power play
back in the capital Armenian forces
managed to push further and further
ahead 2 years into the war and 30,000 to
36,000 deaths later the Bishkek protocol
was signed in 1994 which calls for a
ceasefire between the opposing sides the
ceasefire left Armenia in control of a
substantial large territory not only did
yavan control nearly all of nagoro gabak
but the country also seized seven
adjacent azer bani regions that were not
part of the initial War goal this brings
the total size of occupied territories
to nearly 11,500 Square kilm Which is
far larger than nagor about's 4,400
Square km terrain the territorial
changes were significant for both
countries however perhaps even more
decisive were the demographic changes as
a result of the war about 250,000 azer
Banis from Armenia fled to azerbajan and
roughly another 600,000 AER Banis fled
the conflict Zone in gabak to the
remainder of aeran this brings the total
number of aarani refug refuges and
internally displaced persons to about
850,000 people as for The Armenian side
an estimated 400,000 Armenians fled
aeran and settled in Armenia and
nowadays nagoro gabak is inhabited by
about 146,000 ethnic Armenians however
the total population spread over gabak
taken as a whole is roughly 400,000
people following the ceasefire diplomat
negotiations began president tetran and
his aarani counterpart aliev were close
to a compromise a phased settlement was
accepted by both leaders Armenia was to
return the occupied region surrounding
nagoro gabak and in return azerbajan
would lift the blockade against Armenia
the status of nagoro gabak would be
postponed and settled later on however
ter petosan was forced to step down by
February 1998 by by his prime minister
Karan Karan stalled the peace talks with
aliev but a year later the two sides
were closed to a New Deal Armenia would
return the territory surrounding nagoro
gabak International peacekeeping troops
would be deployed and nagoro gabak
itself would become an autonomy within
azerbajan this second agreement too was
derailed in 1999 when a group of armed
gunmen stormed the Armenian Parliament
killing eight and wounding dozens of
Armenian officials it was never
explained what really happened or what
had motivated the gunman but in a 2005
interview former Russian FSB officer
Alexander laneno stated that the gru the
military intelligence agency of Russia
was behind the shooting in an effort to
derail the peace progress which would
have resolved the gabak conflict no
evidence was provided to support these
allegations but nonetheless the peace
talks were slowed down during the
remainder of karan's presidency it was
only in 2007 when the peace talks gained
momentum with the introduction of the
Madrid principles this road map was
further updated in 2011 and it basically
requires Armenia to withdraw its forces
from the region and calls for
peacekeeping forces instead following
this nagoro gabak would receive security
guarantees and the Region's legal status
would be resolved through diplomacy in
the meantime our Armenia would
temporarily maintain a corridor with
nagoro gabak and azerbajan would lift
the blockade against Armenia and
Communications between the two would be
restored for over a decade the peace
talks have been conducted along these
lines yet the talks are no step closer
to a peace treaty the reason for the
passive negotiations is due to the
changing geopolitics of the region the
fact is that energy rich azer Ban's
economy has skyrocketed and the the
country has forged close strategic
relations with turkey and Israel
furthermore baku's diplomatic influence
has expanded due to its groundbreaking
energy policy and at the same time
Armenia has been absorbed into the
Russian sphere of influence with Iran
being the closest geopolitical
alternative essentially in the duration
of the peace talks the regional
geopolitics have shifted today there
exists an asymmetric balance between
aeran and Armenia yavan wants to
maintain the status quo whilst Baku
seeks to use its new leverage to
overthrow the stalemate the dynamic
geopolitical circumstances combined with
the lack of trust have resulted in the
forment of a peace treaty this was a
Caspian report by m Shivan I want to
thank the following people for their
contributions on patreon their support
and that of many others have made this
report possible for more information
information on supporting the Channel
please visit patreon.com/crashcourse